[Music]
after Blade Runner implanted itself into
the minds of moviegoers back in 1982
elements of its cyberpunk world and
story would echo throughout pop culture
for decades to come
despite writers filmmakers and game
designers telling stories in similar
worlds with outstanding results
the familiar dark rainy streets grimy
neon lights and cautionary tales of body
augmentations remained seemingly
steadfast with that in mind it's a small
revelation to see polish studio Bluebird
team take early cues from these
influences and use them as a springboard
to create something new and exciting
with observer you there
yeah I'm a year set in the year 2080 for
observer tells the story of Daniel as
our ski played by blade runner's Rutger
Hauer Lazar ski is a detective who works
the despair ridden streets of Krakow
under the direction of the leading
corporation of the fifth polish Republic
Kyra the world at large has gone to ruin
a digital plague killed thousands of
Augmented people and a colossal war
wiped out any previous global
superpowers thanks to this all-consuming
conflict Chiron rose from the ashes and
became the leading authority and
manufacturer of basically everything
Lazar ski takes jobs from his contact at
Chiron and using his body tech is able
to violently jack into the minds and
memories of people alive or dead to
track clues and solve crimes hence his
official title observer Lazar C gets
called to a slum in the worst part of
Cracow and this is where the majority of
the game takes place talking to
residents examining crime scenes and
deciphering clues make up a lot of the
gameplay here indicating the killer was
in a frenzy but it's all housed inside
gorgeously detailed environments the
twisted memories of deranged strangers
and one of the most intriguing cyberpunk
narratives in years the society that has
been carved out in this apartment
building is all that matters and it's
here that observer starts to pull away
from his influences and blaze its own
unique trail Lazar skis slowly unravels
events with his Augmented technology by
scanning crime scenes for either
biological or electronic evidence he
also makes use of his Dream Eater
augmentation which is designed to
observe people's minds
throughout the course of the game it is
these extraordinary sequences that
present the horrific story beats in
psychedelic and surreal ways from
terrifying nightmare worlds and game
designs that border on mad genius both
you and Lazar ski emerged from these
sessions mentally exhausted but also
instantly compelled to push forward to
find out what happens next
exploration discovery and human
interaction drive the narrative forward
in these bloody crime scenes and filthy
apartments the ability to open a door
inches at a time as another sense of
sweat-soaked tension to the game and
whether it's scanning ID tags and
illegal body mods or sneaking a look at
the tenant list before the janitor comes
back it all pushes you deeper into
observers illusion hallways creak as you
stalk from door to door listening to
bizarre noises rising from each
apartment the crackle of terrified
residents through speakers broken video
screens blasting static and the
cacophony of rain storms envelop you in
an uncomfortable tale mixed with the
truly disturbing sounds coming from
somewhere in the basement and an ominous
industrial soundtrack observers clutches
become almost impossible to escape
[Music]
don't be afraid I'm here to help though
there are times unfortunately where
there are a couple of moments that will
be frustratingly jarring more than once
you're forced to engage in some instant
fail cat-and-mouse sequences that don't
really fit with the overall tone of what
observers trying to create
however they are brief and over within a
few minutes and problems like this are
quickly forgotten when you're lost in a
discussion with a tenant telling you
about his religious order which rejects
body modifications children of the
immaculate hope or slowly discovering
the oppressive extent of Chiron's reach
from desktop computers to picture frames
and that's why observer succeeds as well
as it does every scene as a meaningful
piece of the puzzle to a world and story
that you want to immediately know more
about it consistently presents surreal
moments and surprises that would seem
like on paper the work of lunatics
however in this grimy and hopeless
corner of Krakow they feel completely at
home the writing for even the most
fleeting characters even dead ones feels
genuine every person here from crappy
parents yelling at their kids to
abstract constructs of lost souls
trapped in their own minds has a
convincing life of their own and it's
that commitment to detail that makes
Lazar skeeze descent into his future
hell and his own personal demons all the
more compelling cyberpunk is a
reflection of where we're headed as a
society and oddly alluring reality we've
allowed impressive technology into our
lives at the cost of our own humanity
this is a nice genre that needs new
revisions a new pioneers so we can keep
evolving as we inch closer to seeing its
fictional warnings play out in real life
an observer adds to the familiar
parables and fascinating and unexpected
ways in that respect and on many other
levels observer is a haunting and
remarkable achievement
you